hey Jake with the doctor day he has
hopefully included two working for so
doesn't even color class because it had
a bit older boys the answer he's arrived
on is they set it on five you could have
written that as a decibel how would you
write that as a decimal negative down or
you do it one else if we will come back
to your second richer this is negative 1
point 4 okay I that same number i didn't
ask you to provide in any particular
hall which means you can provided any
form of life I'm you can see I won't go
through he's working because it is all
there but you can see it every step and
he's got a little bit I see a step here
15 to 34 and that's the bit line right
can you see the goal he's working
towards right he's methodically trying
to get what's the final line X by itself
we have a fancy name for that we subside
women s whatever is not over there we
closed on we call it the subject of the
equation all right exit the subject to a
loquacious and so he wanted to get rid
of that three and then he'd wanted to
get rid of hundred you showing it all of
his exes and all appears these new
models the concerts together and it goes
down down then so thumbs up okay now the
question too just a quick shot his
pickup in on bike they don't buy yes
fantastic thank you good now I don't
love you looked it just weed it out
because it does look unusual however one
of the strategies that we try and teach
you mathematically sometimes the problem
just resistivity but one of the main
primary happy to use is just sort of
have a look at the particle that is all
that you can start with if I have a look
at this the immediate place that my mind
goes
to this guy over here you see that if
you just cover up the rest of the
question I could do that I can do one
plus one right like I know it's early in
the morning but I think I can manage
that once you deal with that you pull
back a little bit right haha you could
do what plus a heart you can manage that
and then you sort of unfold the question
as you go and it's really not as bad as
books now Arizona fire again you could
have written that a decibel what is it
and definitely a prediction now i just
want to point out before we move on to
the last one you can see that kind of
patentees is it that i could have kept
going tonight instead of having that
final one i could have written another
one over one plus one over one and it
can go on forever if it if you want to
live a lot in object as a special
mathematical neighbor called fine some
of you may have heard of it as with
golden ratio the really really important
number we have the time to court now
that you're curious it's like a cool
raison d'etre all right last one number
three do we have agreement on this a lot
by the way if the number has agreement
there's something that we need to able
to it it's not just a number it's going
to be units right because it's a surface
area so it should be we're sending okay
i won't go ahead and solve excuse again
we do have to work cool but in case you
can't remember you don't really have
enough measurement on here to solve the
whole question right you've got to add a
few things on sorry so where would you
put some constructions on Turkey can
anyone suggest where they might put the
first additional my run
yeah good so you can see this length
along here is 54 but for it to be useful
to us you need to divide it by 2 which
gives you 27 why is that useful yeah I
knew fantastic so you can see in here
you're right in the middle and this will
be a lot easier if you drew a diagram
some of you could maybe see it well
enough but I'm the kind of person who
needs to be able to draw on something as
you can tell okay so once you've drawn
that in you can see the triangle you've
got this side down here this side over
here and if you have a look actually
though you didn't end up writing it if
you have a look the next thing I would
do is Pythagoras okay why is that final
length over here on the right why is
that useful yay Laura okay it's the
slant height right you already have the
perpendicular height that's not good for
surface area you need the plant height
once you've got it off you go okay